[Music]
the nfl sent out a memo to all teams on
wednesday telling them something they
already knew if a player works out
anywhere but at the club facility and
suffers an injury
that prevents him from playing he need
not be paid even if that player is
working out
in an effort to get himself ready
for the season you still face the loss
of your salary it's something that the
teams can determine on a
player-by-player basis it's a rule
that's been in place i'm told since 1977
you get injured away from work that's
right this isn't just a skydiving
rock climbing skiing motorcycle accident
no this is i'm going down to planet
fitness and i'm going to get myself in
shape because training camps coming oh
well yeah blew out an achilles sucks for
you we don't pay you
and that memo
i didn't i don't need anyone from the
league to tell me this to know this one
that memo wasn't meant for the teams
got that memo right this memo was
seizing on the juwan james situation to
both rub it in the faces of the nflpa
increase whatever division there may be
between management and rank and file and
let the players know yeah that's
right
you need to get your asses to work right
because you got free insurance
you get your medical care provided for
you you think that the broncos are going
to pay for juwan james achilles tendon
repair hell no they ain't going to pay
him his 10 million they're not going to
honor his guarantees they're not going
to kick him to next year and guarantee
they're going to avoid his guarantees
and they may go get three million of his
signing bonus money i mean that that's
the risk you take and it's a shame that
juan james ends up being yeah the guinea
pig for this experiment that the nflpa
launched but but that's what's going on
and chris just earlier this week
the union was trying to get the rookies
and the undrafted free agents to not
show up for rookie minicamp and the
agents who are on the call i'm told
someone were like what the hell are you
trying to do of course these guys are
going to go for a lot of the guys where
else are they going to live they put
them up in a hotel
they put they give them free room and
board yeah while they're trying to get
settled into their new town it's a
perfect transition you got five six
weeks
where you're you're staying in a hotel
doesn't cost you a penny you're getting
fed every day
and you're also putting in the work
necessary to get your
coach
to think maybe this is a guy i want to
keep on my roster it's ludicrous it's
ludicrous and we always support the
players and we are supporting we are
just not supporting we're not supporting
the people that are talented right who
have
a warped view of what's right for the
young players yeah that's exactly right
i mean at least that's that's the way i
view it i'm with you
yeah i mean i don't really don't
understand
you know i mean really what the nflpa is
thinking with this this whole approach
and you're right it seems like it's just
the veteran players have hijacked the
situation completely but in no way does
it do any anybody really any good to be
away from the facility and what i would
say to any players out there like that
are watching the show or if i had to
talk to any of them unless you were
absolutely one of the two or three best
players on the team and then at a young
part of your career
right
like the guy that's a good player like
just a good player let's say not say the
top top three or four best players let's
say it's the seventh or eighth best
player and he's in year eight or nine
like and you've got a pretty good salary
cap uh number like you got to get your
butt in there
i mean it's a joke it's the joan james
situation all those guys so like if
you're not a star if you're not invol
homes or chris jones or tyree kill
or the first round pick or the second
round pick
then you need to get your ass in the
facility because you're the rest of you
are all subject to be juwan james right
that's that's a new phrase you got you
got juwan james you get hurt they're
gonna screw you over they're not gonna
pay you there's a civil war going on
right now between the nfl and the nfl pa
and this is the nfl's
greatest avenue to
support their coaches to get the players
back in the facility and running a
football team the way it should be run
not the way some older veteran players
think it should be run it makes no sense
what the nflpa is doing right now
i was talking to a coach about this
yesterday and we were trying to figure
out where that break-even point is for
the young players yeah i think you hit
it round three is where you need to be
there because
round three you're going to be on the
bench you're you're you know
right round four you may be gone right
five six seven probably will be gone
undrafted undrafted free agent
i'm not coming to the voluntary
off-season program all right you're not
coming at all then right see ya right
we'll cut you and we'll go find somebody
else so you know this is all up and
that's the other thing too if you want
to exert leverage against the league
you don't pick a fight that is only
going to piss off the coaches
the league doesn't care about this the
owners don't care it doesn't cost them
any money if the guys don't show up in
fact they save the per diem they save
the hotel
room right right they save the food and
if someone gets juwan james they save 10
million yeah that's right so the owners
are not troubled by this the owners are
are far less troubled by this than they
are by a strike a strike they'll go find
other players well you know what you
don't show up for offseason workouts we
already got other players and you get
injured on your own we already got other
players we're going to have 53 when
september rolls around and those 53 are
going to be ready and if you don't want
to be one of them that's your call yeah
so that's another reason why this thing
is so bizarre to me and chris people
still can't figure out what's going on
there isn't a clear
message from the union it's why they're
doing this they use the pandemic as the
cover for it they don't care about the
pandemic no they don't go get vaccinated
if they did right
why are you concerned about protocols
that worked last year and that are safer
than if you go down everywhere else
right presumably right um
you know you've got guys who are still
upset about the 17 game season well that
was coming no matter what it's either
going to come through negotiations the
easy way or it's going to come through a
lockout the hard way and then you've got
the veterans who don't want to go and
they don't want the young guys to be
there either who are going to
potentially take their jobs and so it's
this amalgamation of reasons and this is
just a fight not to have and i think the
reason why and i don't know this but i
think dee smith the nfl pa executive
director is probably not
fighting this because he thinks this is
the way that some of these guys who are
still pissed off about what happened
last year because there were plenty of
guys who were against the cba this is
kind of their way to work it out of
their system like politically internally
let's go ahead and let those guys you
know they're mad right they got some
steam that they want to release let's
let them release their steam this way
which is fine for them it's not fine for
juwan james who's out 10 million bucks
and maybe a lot more well that's why
it's like
the other thing that i i hope
you know resonated or resonate right i
don't know if you had the id on the end
of that or not
with people or fans out there
is just again what anything showed and
something you've brought up and of
course i know too
because i've witnessed it
the how many players are clueless about
the rules and laws of the nfl and the
cba they don't really know
they have no idea i mean could it be any
more shocking that the
biggest star in our sport the number one
guy
was like wait what he was working out
for football and they're not gonna pay
him
guys don't know
a lot of the ins and outs and details of
what's going on in the league especially
with this type of stuff it's really rare
you know in their locker room in my
experience you know i would say it's
like
a handful of guys that really understand
you know all those different things like
when i was in tampa right hey derek
brooks john lynch rondae barber
um trying to think of some other guys
that probably were all over it like
brian griese was there with me all over
it brad johnson they understood
everything that was going on you could
go to them and ask them but the rest of
the guys were totally clueless and if
they didn't ask or have like some
questions about this or that or this
they they didn't know oh i'm going to
play basketball today oh what i tore my
acl you're not going to pay me yeah i
didn't know that was a rule that's very
common and that's just a it's a big
issue if the nflpa wants to get some
more power in this situation or any
situation and it's it's a significant
element of power that the teams have
that they can decide player by player
and if patrick mahomes and shireen
williams mentioned last night he's down
in texas working out if he pops in
achilles
the chiefs aren't going to do anything
about it
and there are certain guys on every team
that are still going to get their money
remember when teddy brewski had a stroke
and he had a hole in his heart and
missed a season patriots still paid him
right right he was a core member of the
team they loved the guy he did
everything right he checked every box he
was a leader they weren't going to stiff
him but if he was a guy who'd been a
constant pain in the ass
and not showing up for voluntary
offseason workouts and agitating and
doing his own thing and you know just
being a pr they're not going to they're
not going to pay that guy that's up
sorry sorry we don't we don't have any
responsibility to you so that the teams
have a huge amount of power
the players need to understand that and
each individual player needs to make
that decision
do i work out
on my own do i work out at the facility
do i sit on the couch
wrap myself in bubble wrap eat pork
rinds and watch bowling homer simpson
style you got to make that decision with
your agent what's right for you given
your relationship with the team your
contractual realities and i'd say for
most teams most players probably a good
idea if you're going to work out at all
to work out at the team facility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports